i can say i gave it up everything i had
i mean every week you know so
you know and maybe it means an
interception on fourth and eighteen when
you're down ten because i don't care
uh
that it's gonna say two interceptions
you know i really don't it's just like i
ain't quitting
so i think that i think i think that
that um
doing it with so many guys over you know
14 years
and and going to the locker room win or
lose and i can take that gun
we're sure we thought we fell short
but or we won you know
but shoot i couldn't try it any harder
so i think
two different kind of elements there but
uh i think that's the two things that
come to my mind
brow pan
all right thanks man all right guys
phillip rivers after his final game with
the charges he knew it at the time and i
think the rest of us did too peter king
this is not the biggest domino to fall
in the 2020 offseason he wears number 12
for now with the new england patriots
but it's the first real domino we
expected it but there was some some i
don't know just a little bit of a
surprise a little bit of reality setting
in yesterday when the chargers and
phillip rivers jointly announced that
rivers who's already moved out of
california back to alabama rivers will
not be back with the chargers
in
2020 he'll move on they'll move on and
it again it felt inevitable but
there's just there's something sad about
a run that began back in 2004 for player
and team coming to an end
mike i think the difference is
that
tom brady was scheduled to be a free
agent
since the beginning of last season
so we knew that
and although
half of the free world
still believes absolutely categorically
there's no way he won't resign with the
patriots which i think you and i
disagree with
uh we didn't know about philip rivers it
it seemed like at the end of the season
it was heading in this direction but
there was no guarantee
and you know to me
i think the sad part of this is that um
you know i think phillip rivers
was a gallant
uh
you know incredibly good competitor
and you know he's always people are
always going to say you know he never
won a super bowl
which is true there's a lot of
quarterbacks who never won a super bowl
ted williams never won a world series
uh carl malone never won an nba
championship that's the way life goes
you know
the the best players at their position
don't always win titles
and i think phillip rivers was clearly
among the best players at his position
you count on them every single week and
look the last year last two or three
years he threw too many interceptions we
all saw it
but i think that and and
as far as the hall of fameness of him
there will be time for that i don't know
if he's a hall of famer i don't know if
eli manning's a hall of famer but to me
if i'm thinking of phillip rivers i'm
thinking of a guy who was a great not a
good but a great teammate
and a guy who had an excellent nfl
career
well unlike eli manning the career will
continue for phillip rivers so the
five-year clock doesn't even start yet
assuming he finds a landing spot and
peter for me i think it became clear the
chargers were going to move on after
that back-to-back prime time games
culminating in the mexico city laws to
the chiefs where he had seven
interceptions in two games that we all
saw it's one thing to quietly have seven
interceptions on a sunday afternoon in a
regional broadcast it's quite another to
have back-to-back games prime time
national television where you total
seven interceptions in those two games
you throw in the bad record this year
for the chargers and going into the new
stadium with the inability to resonate
in la they've got to make themselves
into an la team and philip rivers was
not going to do that it was time for the
chargers to move on it'll be interesting
to see where they go from here i still
think they're going to end up with cam
newton for the chargers and we're gonna
have a draft coming up in an hour and a
half of his best landing spots he's
going somewhere and he told our friend
sam farmer the la times on monday i can
say for certain that i'm playing it's a
two-year maximum whoever the suitors are
i think that would be their hope as well
because you never know how it goes shoot
if we stick it up after one year i'm
probably done if we play really good
they'll probably want to go again so
he's looking for a place where he can
get up to two years no more than two
years basically one year with an option
for a second year he's going to want to
play peter and here's the thing he's not
going to want to be the guy who is the
starter
in the middle of march and then late
april
the team that he signed with drafts a
guy in round one and it's just a
question of when he's going to supplant
philip rivers and i think the contract
he signs will tell us him and everyone
else that he's the guy for 2020 period
that there's not going to be some rookie
that takes over in october or november
or december and and that's where you
know it's not about the money but it's
about the money because the financial
commitment tells everyone he's our guy
period for all of this season and i
think he's not going to want to play
unless he gets that kind of a commitment
yeah i think it's going to be a real
tricky call for some team mike because
you know i can look at we can round up
the usual suspects
right now
we can say that okay if nobody gives
them a starting job flat out absolutely
then where would he go the first two
teams on my list in that case
uh would be indianapolis and chicago
and then if you say after that okay
which of the places that are most likely
to give him the opportunity to start
uh you know 70 80 percent once opening
day rolls around
i would say tampa depending on jameis
winston
i would say carolina depending on cam
newton and i would say new england
depending on tom brady but all of those
things it's just you know what we're all
doing
we're all we're all taking uh we're all
buying lottery tickets because right now
there are 10 quarterback situations in
the nfl
you know i was writing them down last
night
there's 10 quarterback situations in the
nfl that are an absolute total mystery
if number 10 on my list was chicago and
everyone in chicago would say
oh no that's trubisky's job for at least
one more year
is it
i mean i'm sure it is on opening day
but is it going to be trubisky's solid
job if he continues to stink it up in
2020
and here's the challenge and sims and
i've been talking about this peter it's
a game of musical chairs that is coming
up we just don't know whether there's
more butts than seats or more seats than
butts right we don't know that when the
music stops it's going to be
quarterbacks looking around saying
where's my job or it's going to be teams
looking around saying where's my
quarterback and for philip rivers it
could be the smartest play for him is to
wait until after the draft because
there's a chance after the draft there's
going to be a team that says holy crap
we didn't get a starter in free agency
we didn't get a starter in the draft we
need somebody for 2020 we need him now
hey philip rivers come save us he could
get more money and he could get that
clear path to being the guy and peter
there's a philosophical question that is
embedded in all this that philip rivers
is going to have to resolve is he
willing to be basically a ryan tannehill
where you show up is the number two and
you just kind of hope that the starter
either stinks or gets hurt and you get a
chance to play i think and based upon
stuff sims heard about the chargers
maybe sniffing around to marcus mariota
in 2015 or desean watson in 2017 and the
reaction from philip rivers when those
possibilities were broached with him
i don't think he's going to want to go
anywhere where he's not the number one
guy for the full season and if that's
the case it very well could be
that he ends up retiring or at a minimum
waiting waiting for someone to say
philip we need you you're our guy you're
not going to be holding a clipboard
you're not going to be waiting for
someone to get injured or or uh you know
stink you're our guy from the moment you
sign a contract i think that's what he
wants if he doesn't get that i don't
think he's going to play
well that's a good question mike if i
were him i would just look at history
and the history
of quarterback situations where the
number one guy is shaky
and again i'll talk about jacoby
brissett in indianapolis and mitchell
trubisky in uh in chicago
um there's all kinds of strange
quarterback situations
because
look
what is the guarantee let's say for
instance in pittsburgh that ben
roethlisberger can stay healthy yes as
of this morning he's the last person
standing with his original team from the
2004 draft you know among the
quarterbacks i get that but
is he going to last the full season you
know it you know
are the carolina panthers legitimately
interested
in erasing uh and starting over
in their quarterback situation and not
paying cam newton when they have no idea
what cam newton is right now
there are so many questions
about this but
mike i would agree with you
there's only a couple of places where
teams might
jump out
before the draft and say philip we want
you you know like bruce arians let's
just talk about bruce arians for a
second
if
jameis winston as i've said before if he
overplays his hand financially
in this thing if he's not basically
uh fairly reasonable about the amount of
money he wants after a 30 interception
season then i think bruce arians would
very likely just say hey look let's just
go our separate ways
and if that happens if it happens and
these are all my guesses i'm just
reading the tea leaves knowing bruce
aryans and especially mike how bruce
arians changed in his attitude on jameis
winston the last couple weeks of the
season you know first 14 weeks or
whatever he's very supportive jameis is
our guy oh that was a that was a fluke
interception you didn't hear that the
last two weeks of the season but anyway
i'm only making that point to say that
could i imagine
if jameis winston and the bucks
come to loggerheads you know say a week
before free agency begins i wouldn't be
surprised if they go their separate ways
and then that is a place
a coach who loves a veteran quarterback
just like bill belichick a coach who
loves veterans who've got a year or two
left you know
those are the kind of places that i
could see
if he signs before
you know the draft or before the draft
and free agency those are the logical
places
and the buccaneers fascinate me peter
because i can't tell whether or not
bruce arians really means the things
he's saying or whether this is part of
an effort to soften up jameis winston's
expectations financially and just the
flirtation with a guy like philip rivers
is that your leverage play to get
winston to take less because if you fill
his spot with someone else where is he
going to go who's going to want jameis
winston and i'm kind of rooting now for
philip rivers to tampa simply for the
post press conferences because it would
go from gomer pyle with shucks and golly
and darn to lenny bruce with every f
word and curse word and profanity when
aryan shows up so i love the contrast
potentially in tampa bay from philip
rivers to bruce aryans but uh i i
it's not going to be easy for philip
rivers and you know the chargers have
done this guy a favor by not playing
games with him i thought maybe a week or
two ago when jay glazer initially said
that the chargers are moving on from
phillip rivers and then ian rappaport
tried this whole well the chargers are
going to explore their options and maybe
they'll apply the franchise tag i
thought the chargers would actually
consider a tag in trade and maybe
they've realized over the last couple of
weeks it's not going to work because
nobody is going to take on 27 million
plus for one year for philip rivers and
if that's what they've learned over the
last two weeks that they've abandoned
that that strategy and that approach
that doesn't bode well for teams lining
up out the door for phillip rivers i
think if tom brady's in play they're
going to be lining up for tom brady
phillip rivers is in play and i'm not so
sure they're going to be lining up and
that gets me back to the point that i
made
if he's not given that you're our guy
period unequivocally unconditionally
maybe his best play is to wait and and
maybe the weight goes beyond the draft
peter maybe he waits for ben
roethlisberger to get injured again
maybe he's the guy who's going to ride
in on a white horse and save someone in
september or october
look
there was some there's something to be
said
for phillip rivers waiting uh until
august 28th when some quarterback goes
down with an eight-week injury or
whatever who knows
but
i do the one thing i really agree with
you on is that this is going to be
harder maybe than phillip river think
phillip rivers thinks at this moment
i'll say one other thing about tampa bay
i don't think this is a case of bruce
arians or or the general manager jason
light playing games
uh you know or the glazers playing games
and look mike i i've got to tell you
this is my
reading of the tea leaves i've not
talked to aryans or jason light about
this so let's make that very clear
but when i look at this
any logical thinking person
is going to look at the tampa bay bucks
quarterback situation
and at a quarterback jameis winston who
has led the in
the nfl in interceptions since 2015
since 2016
since 2017
since 2018
and in 2019
every one of those time periods jameis
winston has thrown more interceptions
than anybody in football
so if you're the bucks this isn't about
whoa
let's try to slow play this
so that he'll take less money
it's not like you're negotiating with
patrick mahomes here you know you know
where you know you're going to have to
break the bank if i'm the bucks
and if jameis winston isn't willing to
take some what i would say significant
restrictors in that contract i'm shaking
hands and saying good luck
that's not going to be easy to do though
5108 passing yards eighth all-time
single season and the only guys who have
had more production from a yardage
standpoint than him are all
current or future hall of famers that is
well let me ask you this question mike
though we got to take a break you got to
put a pin in it okay
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports